it is one of the most popular
destinations worldwide to view the great
white shark and tourists flock from all
over the globe to hands by on the
Western Cape to experience this they're
getting closer is that just my
imagination chief but look at this many
miles away in a different location a
shark is caught up in a net and destined
to die they've been around for 40
million years but now some believe
they're very much at risk not just from
Nets they die slowly on baited hooks too
sometimes they're hunted their jaws
poached and fin sawn off and sold to
make shark fin soup for mainly Chinese
dinner tables it can mean big profits
dr. Sarah Andreotti has spent the past
seven years compiling the largest
genetic and photographic data set of
shops in the world and she believes it
shows they're headed for extinction
we've been collecting for over 5000 for
identification of white sharks since
2009 and you get to know them you get to
recognize which is which the dorsal fin
works like a fingerprint so they have
these unique dorsal fin and you can
recognize and then you see them coming
back and when you don't see them coming
back is almost like losing a friend is
you were used to be here this time of
the year what what happened to you but
many sharp victims like this fisherman
in Mozambique believe their lives and
their jobs
since then I've developed strong
feelings against the Sharks so I really
believe that Jax must be handed down
because this shark in particular but all
the Sharks in the bay they will keep
coming and coming and attacking more
people so the only solution i see is
peculiar in side the point shark attack
can be devastating and caleb's or pools
traumatic encounter me whatever and I
fall to grip onto me and still looks
like shaking me around who pulled me
under the water I try to push the shock
of my league but I just fought this
thing I sort of grip enter me in this my
teeth I'm bone like crack kind of whole
things that just happened and I'm
thinking here this is it now it's me
gone and afterward I was opposing dial p
this is known as shark alley in hands by
the huge seal population here draws the
sharks but divers noticed if the seals
remain behind the kelp or the seaweed
growing here the Sharks avoided them the
dark circle you see to the left of the
voters environmentally friendly
artificial magnetic camp it's called the
shark safe barrier it's been developed
by dr. Craig O'Connell and Michael
Rutzen who formed a team of scientists
and shark lovers to create an
alternative barrier to protect beaches
fishermen and shops and avoid the need
for nets and hunting and this is the
test site how certain are you that
they're not going to come inside where
we're going to be
well so far we have annual percent
success rate so to my what I think is
that they would not pin will not
penetrate the barrier under any
conditions that we've seen so far let's
give it a go ten meters down in the
middle of the artificial kelp forest
that is the shark safe berrien we are
the live bait and I have pink fins on as
an added lure and mike has placed some
dead fish in a container inside the
barrier as extra motivation for the
Sharks to enter the test site it doesn't
take long Mike on the right points out a
three metre long great white heading
straight towards us it veers away when
it spots the artificial kelp dead rate
and live right
that's the shots back held back by this
fake help madness
the team's discovered there's possible
fewer than 500 22 white sharks left in
the South African population and with
the lowest genetic diversity worldwide
that puts them at real risk I like what
I'm doing this is my life that I chose
I'm doing everything in my power and
capability to try and save them I think
that if we don't do something now they
will go extinct someday but the team is
desperate to protect these huge sea
creatures these curious ones almost the
size of our boat Alex forfeit sky news
in cons once I've ever
you